to those of us brought up on palm and
pac-man the modern video game is a
revelation an immersive and increasingly
realistic experience produced with often
stunning creativity and artistry now a
multi-billion dollar industry gains
revenues now dwarf those of the movies
and games consoles have become
ubiquitous media comes as the technology
driving these games has developed so the
soundtrack is really blossomed once all
electronic and simple although often
very catchy now blockbuster games
require blockbuster soundtracks often
recorded by full symphony orchestras
bafta now has a games music category
acknowledgement perhaps that it's time
to take this genre seriously James
Hannigan has one that BAFTA and be
nominated five times he's one of the
finest composers working in games today
with credits including command and
conquer the lord of the rings and the
theme park series games that are hugely
successful all around the world and that
means the millions of people every
single day are listening to Hannigan's
music the games industry had always held
a fascination for me I played games as a
kid so I was very sort of intrigued by
the production of games music and music
in games was actually going through a
very interesting transition at that
stage was coming out of the so-called
chip music era into the era of digital
music production so all of a sudden it
was possible to play back almost any
music in games anything that we recorded
in games could now be streamed from hard
disk or playback from CD and that really
sort of interested me and I felt sort of
offered many many opportunities for the
vaults get involved in a new and
emerging medium if you don't know how
something's created there's a kind of
magic with music
think that if you you know if you get if
you can't analyze it you can't break it
down and you sort of you just marvel at
something that adds something it's more
than just the music it's the how is that
done how does it achieved and I think
that's a chip music in particular in
early games held that kind of
fascination to me I just wanted to know
how to do it you know just explain chip
music chip music is just music that you
would use the underlying hardware of the
console or you know the game system to
generate sounds they use though the
instrument was the you know the console
that the sound chip it had a uniqueness
and a language that was evolving and it
was immediately identifiable you knew
what games music was when you heard it
I set the tape and a cassette tape to EA
and they they offered me a job and you
know I took it because it was it just
felt like a really good opportunity and
even though as I say it wasn't really
particularly well respected I think I
could see that it where it was heading
and where it still is going you know
I've got great faith in it I want to
bring in theme park well because it's a
game for those of you don't know where
you create your own theme but music wise
this is an interesting one even though
it's a fairly early example of how you
change the music to suit the event that
your cell I mean I think again you know
when you show linear clips of old games
generally they don't impress I mean I've
got to say that because you know they
are there to be played and not to be
viewed and this is a classic example of
that am I right in saying that when when
you build the your Park if you've only
got one thing in it let's say you've
just got one that's what it is you've
got one very very simple bit of music
yeah as you build it up your music gets
more less wine that's why I think it it
won the battle that year so this music
kind of evolved as your Park grew so the
more children there were in your theme
park more rides then the busy you know
the music became more and more dense and
you know that would happen over 45
minutes or something even though
everything we derived from one single
track it was sort of stretching that
track out when you creating music for
games very often you're not working to
picture you know specially with this
kind of God game if you like as they
call it is it's sort of you don't know
what's going to happen next it's all
driven by the player so you can't really
write music that imposes too much on the
game you know there isn't a story
because the player is creating that
story and the story is there park these
must be vaguely curious yeah but you see
that it's more of a concept say the
music is for situations
States it's not sort of oh you know
there's this sequence let's write some
music for it all the music in that
consisted of little segments you know
four or eight bars and those were
endlessly being spliced together by the
interactive music system so you know you
get to the end of one of these little
bars and that could be looped or it
could be followed by another one and you
know it was as branching that was going
on so if the park gets busier then you
know it'll wait to get to the end of the
existing segment go up a gear then it
will dip into a sort of Bank of Bezier
tracks segments so it's a kind of
sentencing thing you just kind of
creating these longer and longer
sentences but it's in it's entirely
driven by the player you know it's sort
of the player is creating the story so
you you're not telling a story with the
music it's just kind of you know
completely determined by them the thing
that I've always wanted to do but
haven't always been successful in doing
is trying to add a dimension to the
games with music because this is
sometimes very little to work with you
know you don't you're not led by the
picture all the time you know you know
you have these situations again it's
what you say with the music so for
example that I mean just is that there
was a managed sports management game
football management game and it just it
basically consisted of spreadsheets so
what music do what you know what's
spread sheet music yes so you know then
again that's the key that you see the
thing in games is that very often things
are interpreted in a very literal way so
that tends to you know there's a
tendency less so now but historically to
just play the music play music that
states the obvious so you know if you're
in a combat situation where you trigger
combat music but what gets overlooked
there is that the player already knows
has a visual
you for the for the combats so why are
you reinforcing that I mean there's a
lot to be learnt from film in that way
because you know maybe the most
effective use of music in a battle
sequence in the film is to have no music
that's what you don't do with music it's
how you set the battle up or how you you
know follow that up with some music
about loss or something you know about
the aftermath of the battle but games
tend to have this kind of its
heightening the excitement so I think
that kind of one over for a while but
then in the case of the other
spreadsheet game we sort of thought well
it was a football game so try and add
some passion we had this kind of
operatic music in there that really sort
of worked against the visuals but it
gave you this sense that it was about
football and the passion so all the
Nessun Dorma it was affirmed yeah
exactly it was about so you know wanting
to win and things like that but even
though you're looking at the spreadsheet
but then you wouldn't you know this kind
of thing it doesn't happen very often I
find in games I'd like to move on to
Republic the revolution but a number of
reasons one is stylistically this is a
what perhaps you can tell us what what
it is well it obviously the subject
matter dictates the the way in which you
approach these yeah I mean this was
quite hyped at the time because it was
again a kind of an strategy game where
you had this view of a city and it was a
sort of political simulation it sort of
you controlled this person who was
trying to rise to power in a fictional
East European State so he was just
trying to get you going around
recruiting people and getting people on
your side and campaigning and things
like that so it had this kind of as a
regional flavor to it but it had quite
quite an advanced interactive music
system that combined a number of these
techniques you know the sort of
horizontal splicer shuffling these
segments we also had Vertical
interactive music as well we're sort of
different stems layers music was sort of
shuffled as well so they all had to be
compatible with one other so you know
you don't know what yet when you're
writing these you have to think about
whether they're compatible with every
other layer and it's a bit of a
nightmare but it was it was interesting
number of the things we talked about so
far have been really rather serious
subject matters often and their role
playing games that that are essentially
rather serious and dramatic I suppose
this is slightly more tongue-in-cheek
world domination yeah exactly you're
just the you know the archetypal evil
genius type Blofeld style character
who's again it's a sort of God game
strategy games a top-down view and you
have your minions and your layer on a
remote island somewhere and you're just
trying to take over the world that's
basically hit so who doesn't want to do
that exactly okay so what was what was
your approach musically um well I mean
it's a bit of a parody on kind of 60 spy
movies that's it they had quite an
elaborate interactive music system again
it had this kind of branching and lots
of music for set pieces and again it's a
sort of fairly early example of
orchestral music you know recorded an 80
piece orchestra for this and a big band
an island far from prying eyes
lurks the genius with an evil plan you
build your evil base
you
recruit your evil henchman
when a consumer like myself has a
playstation 2 and then moves to a
playstation 3 the quality obviously if
the picture is obviously a lot better
and more advanced but does it make any
difference what to you what what are the
differences as far as it sent for you
well yeah in these days it's just that
there aren't many constraints really
it's well there can be under certain
circumstances in it was a DS game or
something but that was the biggest
problem you know we started recording
all this live music say you know said ëi
just calling the Royal College of Music
and saying sent you know some musicians
/ that kind of thing it was pretty fun
but then you record this stuff in a
really nice studio purpose-built studio
they had but then it all ended up
mangled by the compression system they
had at the time because you know if you
think about mp3's now there are pretty
of a high quality a lot of people can
tell the difference between those and
you know wives sort of PCM samples so
that wrecked it you know introduced all
these artifacts and noise and it sounded
really muffled and you used to think
well what was the point of that you know
you record this Orchestra and it just
ends up sounding like it's underwater or
something but now you have 5.1 sound
yeah exes it's okay with the deep why
it's coming to I mean I don't think the
music in games has really improved that
much it's that the industry has become
more mainstream the games have become
bigger and I think if it's the the
popularity of the games really that kind
of creates the I mean sort of brings
about more success in the music you know
the more mainstream that becomes and the
delivery as I say the quality
movie tie-ins are tricky in the sense
that the films are generally king so you
know everything not necessarily derived
from the films but the it's important
sort of maintain the look and feel and
sound of those properties if you like
simply to have the the game world and
the games identifiably connected with
those franchises so I think that's the
hardest thing because you know that
whatever music you right it's going to
be in the shadow of the the film music
and that's you know that can be slightly
upsetting because you know there's
probably there is a perception that the
music in those games is actually derived
from the film music but for various
legal reasons that's rarely the case
music is nearly always original it may
be within the same stylistic framework
but it's it's it's generally new music
unless a specific piece of music as
being licensed from the film you know
maybe it's a shin alee an actual
recording will be used at other times
maybe just the particular composition so
you in the case of Harry Potter there's
a reference to occasional reference to
John Williams Hedwig's theme but that
actually forms of very very small parts
of the writing each company each
developer and publisher has its own
culture that could be in a corporate
culture and its approach to the business
of making music and how they exploit
music and expect it to be produced and
also creatively speaking the other way
the time that it takes to create again
varies considerably some operate a
little bit closer to the the film model
and they go through similar stages of
production kind of pre-production
production post production type model
and they tend to really hit their dates
you know set aside three months for the
music we'll get it done in that time end
of story it comes out that's very much
like the the sort of film industry
model i think but other games companies
really take their time over the
development of games it's a very almost
experimental kind of iterative process
where they develop these games over a
very very long period of time they
replace the endlessly replace content
and that that's slightly harder if
you're an outsider I mean to that to
that particular company because you're
expected to sort of you can be expected
to work on a game for you know upwards
of a year or two so in that sense it can
be quite difficult to manage the the
flow of work because you never really
know when when music going to be needed
how much and you're expected to be on
call no matter what so it can varies
wildly company to company we've got to
this point now where a lot of composers
really are wanting to get into games too
and i'm bound to ask you as someone
who's been doing this for a long while
now what what advice would you give to
anyone who's here who might be
interested in becoming a games composer
how do they do it what should they what
should they be ready for I wish I could
I wish I had an answer no I think and I
think it probably the same way as anyone
would find involvement in the film
industry or TV industry I think you
should link yourself to people who are
starting out in that industry rather
than just sort of I don't know it's do I
you know in the film industry is very
difficult to start at the top of
something isn't it but in most
relationships in films start in film
school you know you'll have a director a
film school use a composer whose at the
film school and then they'll go on and
develop a working relationship and it's
like that in the film industry I mean
partnerships you know some extreme
examples like Spielberg and Williams and
Hitchcock and Bernard Herrmann and they
go on and on working together so i think
it's like that it's all about
relationships i don't think it's about
just about the music it's not about
having a great real you know that's part
of it but i think that wouldn't you know
probably networking is there's a key
part of it unfortunately primarily you
need to be easy to work with the
to get on with that's a key part of it
and I think you need to work to a brief
you need to be able to write the music
that's actually required for the game
you're working on it's not a case of
imposing your favorite music on a on a
game regardless of whether it's
appropriate so stylistic appropriateness
as in film and TV is very significant so
I think you need to be able to move into
new territory all the time and research
music and develop your technique and
expand your capabilities all the time
and essentially be able to go from the
very earliest oversee the development of
music from the very earliest stages of
composition right through to the final
production a lot of the bigger big games
companies have music executives don't
they people are recharged I don't it's
very very few risks taken now so i think
it is hot you i don't think it'd be able
to leap into a big franchise or
something you know an existing yeah and
a big budget game having done nothing
before even if you're capable of doing
it simply because it's just seen as a
risk so but doesn't mean that there
isn't a way in just as I say I think
getting it's a little bit like yeah
instead of going to a big music
publisher go to an up-and-coming band if
you want to you know become one of the
band and then hope that you get signed
and it's the same with the games
industry gets small developers and
startups get in with those people and
then you know be part of their journey
the one question I've left almost to
last is can you play all these games no
hey I suppose you don't have to i think
you should try but do you try yeah I do
like games so yeah I do I mean I
understand them it's just but some of
them are quite hard exactly yeah it's
time isn't it yes yeah you're too busy
writing the music for the next one to
enjoy playing previous one is that right
yeah although I do set aside time to
play through you know there are some
games that I really want to get to grips
with you know I like action adventure
games sort of linear games and these art
of endless world things like I just
don't you know I can't get into those
RTS things and he just plain forever I
like there to be a beginning in the
middle of an end I think market is
growing all the time in many areas
there's a sort of blockbuster end of it
there's the equivalent of the sort of
film industry's independent sector
that's emerging so there are so many
outlets for music and the creativity in
general when it comes to the the games
medium that I think it has a very very
bright future it can only grow in
significance
Oh
Oh
Oh